the government have tried to ruin
landlords come on get real hey what's up
my name's Samuel Leeds and the
government have tried to ruin landlords
they've tried to kill property investing
over the last few years but you know
what happened it's bad fired it's really
badly backfired because the smart
landlords are more successful wealthier
than they've ever been before and the
thing that freaks me out I'm just
reading all this stuff right now from
The Telegraph the media I've changed
their tune so badly before three years
ago they were saying oh I - let doomed
now they're saying why the government
attack on by - that landlords has
completely back by it we all knew it was
gonna backfire watch my videos from 2016
2016 when George Osborne said landlords
could no longer claim that mortgage
payments as tax deductable whenever was
good it was oh my gosh what we're gonna
do and I was saying guys it's cool man
it's absolutely fine what we're going to
do is we're gonna set up companies we're
gonna continue buy the houses and
section 24 the tax changes do not apply
and on top of that relat SAR gonna go up
because of section 24 George Osborne who
said he was trying to help the
first-time buyers and tenants actually
he's gonna make us richer that's what I
said in 2006 did you go back watch the
videos I said rents are going up I said
buy through companies and I also started
advocating and teaching serviced
accommodation now what's happening now
the government again upset because
they're saying everyone's new service
accommodation apparently now in London
7% of the total housing stock our Airbnb
listings and now they say oh there's not
enough properties for tenants what do
you expect of course there's not enough
properties for tenants oh no rents have
gone up by 4.5% in London the last 12
months and even more the year before in
the year before you guys know you know
what you're doing you know that all the
rules are created to make the rich rich
and the poor poorer because the people
that make up the rules are the same
people that invest in property come on
get real
I'm gonna leave a link to the Telegraph
in this description as some people might
think I'm crazy you know someone's crazy
what's he all about listen I'm not crazy
you watched my videos from three four
years ago no three years ago when they
first bought it takes 24 you watch my
videos yeah everyone would say I'm gonna
hold off I'm gonna hold off because it
breaks it don't hold off just get smart
man
get smart and get rich and this is where
the government is just complaining about
how rich there are rules again the
intention is always for the rich to get
richer and the poor to get poorer listen
I don't make up the rules I just follow
them I learn them
I study pans and I follow them I'm
shocked at some of the stats it's crazy
but I'm also shocked they're pretending
to be shocked you know what's happening
my advice is to get learn ette get
knowledgeable stop scrolling through
Facebook in the morning and start strong
in through the Financial Times and start
reading up stop spending your weekends
at home watching the TV and start coming
on some property investment programs and
getting smart if you don't want to get
smart that's no problem but never mode
that you're broke as time goes on you're
gonna end up having to choose it you're
gonna be poor or you're going to be rich
because the divide is gonna get bigger
and bigger are you gonna just be relying
on the government and listening to the
media or are you gonna choose to listen
to wealthy people and get smart and get
rich at the moment you can kind of just
about sit on the fence and be
comfortable but that's going to change
over the next 10 years you watch that's
my next prediction in the next ten years
you're gonna have to choose you're going
to be rich or you're going to report the
divide is getting bigger and it pisses
me off maybe you can even tell that I'm
irritated by this the reason I'm
irritated is because of the lies that
are told as if they are so shocked they
knew what was happening I knew what was
happening but I'm the only person that
was saying it no one else was saying
this so get rich get educated I'm done
[Music]